find the number of books that can be
printed for three thousand dollars so
now how am I reading where am I going to
go yeah i'm going to start from my
vertical axis there's three thousand
right there so that's coming across to
looks like about there did I ya know
three thousand yeah let me I'll just do
some would not be go ok so Hoover that's
that's convincing that's 3,000 old so
now when I read down clearly I'm between
here and here do you agree with that
what's your horizontal scale looking
like how would you judge that what does
each square represent I think it's 20
isn't it like if you look carefully
let's look at the first one here I've
got one two three four five marks that
get to 100 five months ago to 100 that's
gonna be 20 right five twenties so
therefore here this looks like 200 220
240 this is 260 which means the next one
is 280 and looks like I'm just
underneath that are you happy with how
I've read that so I'm going to say
probably just below just blew the 280
right so again I can't say to it because
I know it's not on the line so I'm going
to say yo SE 275 that is close enough
for me I don't know how much exactly but
that's all ok now we're going to do a
bit of interpretation because this is
not just some random X and some random
why ok this is actually black quantities
from the real well so find the gradient
what is its meaning alright let's wrap a
few things off the survey which do you
remember when I showed you that that
graphing software before i send all look
here some triangles this is how to find
the gradient where are you going to look
here what points would you pick because
we can choose yeah i want something
that's like close to a grid line like an
intersection ok all right hold on boss
boss so I think someone said a hundred
eighty a greater which is there that
looks pretty good doesn't it like that's
pretty much bang on this point here I'm
happy with that that's one point I need
another 1 2 20 that's fear yeah that's
pretty good ok I won't pause I could use
this for our particular table and
actually not going to panel reason why
is that if you can imagine it this way
the smaller your scale is the easier it
is to miss read it does that make sense
like for example if I were comparing two
numbers and the rise over one was like
10 take away eight on a go for take away
three if I'm off by one off by wanting
like it's a nine instead of 10 ok the
difference between those is quite
significant what's what's the green in
here to over 1 which is too if I miss
read this 10 just buy one and make it
nine what's the greedy now it's one
that's drastically different right so
the smaller my numbers are the closer
they are together the more liable I make
myself to like errors inaccuracies ok so
even though I think that'll be ok I'm
actually going to look for a further one
because it reduces the error that I'm
gonna happen yeah matter ok what 468 ok
then that looks like it's here which
comes all the way up until uh where is
it is it right on it tore it up
there that looks pretty good to me that
is also just like the one Renee p also
pretty much on a point but because it's
so much brother away I'm going to have a
better chance at getting a more accurate
than life rather than this happening so
let's get this down gradient and I think
it's helpful to write its rise over run
it's equal to ok now have a look at the
rise first so I'm going to take part of
this line off now because now I have my
it's a bit off now my triangle in there
I've got rise here run here what's the
rise equal to what's the top number you
read that is its 4,500 right so that's
where I i I've gone up to and have to
take away what if this number of done
here was right what is that nobody yeah
it's between 2002 500 so that's 2 250
whatever that ends up being ok so I'm
gonna put that in here in a second I
just might as well while we get the
graph I might as well work out the run
ok what's this number over here what if
we select 460 wasn't it so for 60 and my
starting point is I think we said 180
anyway 180 does that look good to you
yeah first there we go 180 so for 60
take away 18 that's going to give me the
bun so rise looks to me like that's 2250
someone can check that in the calculator
for me if they want I'm 460 take away
180 is 280 it's ready I think yeah
dad / that okay I'm going to need to
calculate for this one I don't know how
to do that in my head can someone give
me a number to give me a few decimal
places walks I assume they'll be decimal
places yep okay now we've written all
these but we know we know ourselves that
these are probably not exactly wrong so
we're going to self approximate because
we know this is not perfect like what is
what are these decimal points off hear
me probably nothing because we were kind
of doing our best on the ground so I'm
going to say you know what I think
that's run out of space just here i'm
going to say that date either it's close
like I think this point zero three is so
so falsely accurate like I don't really
know I'm that precise okay here's the
really important question that's the
gradient what's its meaning what does it
correspond to do you remember we had a
look at the graph there's what's right I
said Oh gradient one means you go across
one here you got one there or gradient
to means you go across wider you go up
to cross one up to so every time you go
across what do you add it you're adding
weight hot on second and every time you
gotta cross cross you're adding one book
and when you go up you're adding a
dollars right eight dollars one book so
what does that mean like what's the
meaning of Draya it's the price of one
book right that's what the gradient
means in this particular on this
particular graph right so I'm going to
conclude now I'm going to say this this
number is not just a number it's
attached to a context right therefore
this means each book costs and i'm going
to say approximately as well between you
is approximate cost approximately eight
dollars to print
okay they're almost finished right last
question party what's the vertical
intercept it also is not something
precise so do your best what does it
look like to you yeah so this this mark
here which I'm not on it's halfway
between 500,000 which is 750 just above
that right so in fact I'm even going to
write that i'm going to say just above
750 and i think a reasonable just above
is a hundred now again the important
question what does that mean what does
that indicate have a look at the UM
horizontal axis well howdy books you
printing maybe yeah nothing yum printed
anything at this point so what's at
eight hundred dollars going to suck on a
box now I will probably say even the
paper is I'll just finish this and then
we'll pack up don't pack of you i would
say papers a thing but I think paper is
included in this like the more books you
print the more paper you use I think
this has to be something else apart from
paper what else could be so Janine okay
like the machine right like this
printing press whatever you've actually
put it use it first like you've got to
get ahold of it the factory maybe that
is publishing these books is pretty it's
going to say you wanna use my machine
you're going to be some money just to
get in the door right so i would call
these startup costs
so this is how much it costs before
you've made any books you've got to get
that edge of the doors out of the way
and then after that every book eight
dollars